you need control speed
and power
along with some swag very nice
power laces all right hey everybody it's
charlie hopefully you've had a chance to
see black panther this weekend these are
gonna be my easter eggs
obviously a whole bunch of avengers
marvel cinematic universe stuff that
they crammed in there but
mostly easter eggs from the black
panther comics some really deep cuts for
real life black panther party stuff too
be sure to subscribe to get everything
if you're just finding me for the first
time there's so much marvel stuff that's
going to be happening between now and
infinity war and there's an infinity
gauntlet giveaway going on i'll name a
new winner at the end of this too
so just blanket spoiler warning for
black panther if you have not seen it
yet i'll wait just a second
okay so here we go so the movie picks up
with a 1990s flashback
and it's a very black panther party
easter egg the party has its roots in
oakland but also ryan coogler himself
is from oakland so he wanted to go back
there and incorporate some of those
ideas like militarizing the black
panther party in the oppressed peoples
around the world and sort of tie that
into a more real world message of black
panther so here's we get into some
really fun stuff though you go into
their apartment there's an nwa poster
on the wall they were a really huge
hip-hop group that embraced a lot of the
ideals of the black panther party
the young version of t'chaka is wearing
the older marvel knights version of the
costume with the gold highlights from
the christopher priest run
it was a very urban black panther story
it was him in new york city so it makes
sense that you have them in this urban
setting that you would do a version of
that
but even better the actor that's playing
young tachaka
is the real life son of the actor that
plays the current version of t'chaka
the opening credit sequence that
explains the origins of vibranium
actually shows us captain america's
plane
crashing as it flies by during the world
war ii part of the history scene
is really the entire history of the
world that they show from the dawn of
early man to all the stuff that we've
seen in the marvel cinematic universe so
far in present day
but they also pay tribute to the very
first black panther
which was actually in a comic book
recently where they did the ancient
version of the avengers
where odin was sort of the thor of the
team along with the very first version
of the black panther
the whole reason for king t'chaka to go
visit his brother
in oakland was because of that original
ulysses claw high so it explains where
he got the vibranium
from that he sold to ultron that they
then teased
would be given back to black panther
eventually so remember there's still a
lot of
loose cycovian vibranium in the world
but i think largely they sewed up that
plotline at the end of the movie when
they said the black panther would be
working with the world to try and
exchange
technology so if it wasn't clear black
panther's people do try to keep tabs on
everyone in the world that has access to
vibranium
but really sad to see ulysses claw go
maybe they'll release that mixtape turns
out he really is a musician
really minor stanley cameo not quite as
big as we expected
i'll just take that and put it over here
not quite as big as the guardians of the
galaxy cameo i'm expecting them to top
that for infinity
war in avengers 4. i'm assuming that
they've filmed all of stanley's cameos
back to back they said that because of
his advanced stage
a lot of times they'll just have him
film a bunch of green screen scenes and
then just insert those into the movies
later on
we got a namor reference from the comics
for everybody hoping that they use him
for the sequel
when he takes clawin and says every
breath you take is mercy from me
that's actually directly lifted from a
black panther vs namor moment in the
comics
really early on that freaky mask the
killmonger wears is actually made to
look like the mask the character in the
comics wears obviously much more tribal
in the comics they changed his origin
story quite a bit
originally the name killmonger was just
something that he chose for himself he
did go to school in the united states in
the comics but his father had been
originally
forced to fight for ulysses claw when he
was trying to invade wakanda and steal
all their vibranium
they were fought off black panther's
father exiled all of the people who
rebelled against him
and that's how killmonger's family wound
up in the united states so he grew up
there
and vowed revenge for the disgrace to
his family felt like it was totally okay
that the movie changed that to turn him
into more of a hamlet lion king type
character
but speaking of character changes
obviously mbaku just completely omitted
the
man ape origin of the character in the
comics the only small references that
they make to that are calling him the
great gorilla
he wears an ape mask made to look just
like the one that he wears in the comics
when he's fighting black panther
earlier in the film and the entrance to
his palace is carved to look like that
of an
ape so that's about as close as they get
to that for obvious reasons
pretty sure everybody picked up on that
back to the future reference when she
gives him the sneakers just like michael
j
fox's sneakers from back to the future
too apparently black panther's father
was a huge fan of those movies
also pretty sure everybody detected that
the broken white boy that shuri was
talking about was winter soldier great
another broken white boy for me to fix
i'm hoping that vision is another broken
white boy in the next movie
i made a reference about that during my
avengers video and i'm not sure people
understood what i was talking about
but i've already done a couple videos
explaining how she fixed his mind
but effectively he is back to normal
she'll give him a vibranium arm
and they're calling him the white wolf
which is probably one of the bigger
easter eggs
hopefully sebastian stan signs a new
marvel contract and they can use him in
future marvel sequels but he does seem
like he's down to do that so maybe
white wolf in black panther 2. the movie
changed a little bit about black
panther's powers the heart-shaped herb
and the dijalia
the way the movie depicted it it's
really of your own creation it's sort of
this psychic
area that you just travel into and it's
just made to look like the place that
you're thinking about the most so that's
why
killmonger goes back to the place where
his father died in why black panther
meets his father amidst all these acacia
trees and if it wasn't clear
those other panthers in the tree are the
spirits of previous versions of black
panther so in the comics he's the king
of the dead he can speak to the previous
versions of black panther and get advice
from them
this is the movie's way of invoking that
the first time that he talks to his
father
they stay panthers when he goes back the
second time to talk to his father and
ask him why he left killmonger
behind as a child you see them all in
human form the reason why they're all
male
is because they're all the previous
black panthers this
is how i think it's possible they can
bring killmonger back
in the second film because they're
pretty clear that he wanted to die at
the end of the last film so unless black
panther defied his wishes
and threw him into cold storage to heal
him he's going to be dead
but here's the thing because he had
taken in the heart-shaped herb
and communed with the panther goddess so
it's possible that black panther could
go to the spirit plane and speak to
killmonger spirit and that's how you
bring michael b jordan back
because he was a fantastic character
maybe they'll find a way to incorporate
him
maybe in a flashback there's just a
number of ways they could accomplish
that
there were a couple more iconic comic
book panels when killmonger
tosses black panther over the falls
that's right out of the comics
also when black panther is charging on
the rhinos i know everybody wants to see
those come back during infinity war
and then like i said the marvel knights
version of the costume in that 90s
flashback
they also kind of did the same thing
with the more modern version of the
costume the killmonger wore towards the
end of the film
big disneyland big coachella shout out
at the end of the film there's only
theories at this point that black
panther is the person who bought stark
tower because that was being sold at the
end of spider-man homecoming
new tenant moving in but remember
timeline explainer
black panther takes place about a week
after captain america civil war
the events of spider-man homecoming take
place several months after that
so if you don't know when civil war
happened that was during the summer
because it was his
summer retreat with the avengers in that
homecoming dance is usually something
that happens around october for most
people in the united states
so the end of black panther takes place
a couple months before the end of
spider-man homecoming
so don't worry we'll do more timeline
explainers as we get closer to infinity
war
because the movies don't take place one
right after the other in the timeline
anymore
the other real big comic book easter egg
is when they talk about how they
lied and say ulysses claws stole all
their vibranium you told us that it was
all gone and you didn't have anymore
dr doom ulysses claw and thanos himself
all on separate occasions tried to take
all of wakanda's vibranium
there was a time in the comics when
black panther was forced to render
all vibranium in the world inert on a
more permanent basis
and for those of you asking there
actually is vibranium
in the savage land but remember we don't
have the x-men characters yet so as of
right now in the mcu the only place you
can get it is inside the borders of
wakanda
well let me know in the comments if you
spotted any other easter eggs that i
didn't mention in the video
what'll happen is i'll be doing more
avengers more black panther related
stuff in the next couple of weeks
obviously as we head towards infinity
war
in deadpool 2 there's going to be so
much stuff dropping
so there any special videos that you
want me to do just let me know in the
comments
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner jmv please private message me so
i can get your contact details there was
a new round on this video i'll just name
a winner when i post new marvel
click here to learn about all the
infinity gems after black panther and
click here for my black panther post
credits scene video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you